yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master lingo from from Norway and down
let's play the Banco for a change let's
see what is coming up with the classical
line yeah this liner got a boost in
popularity recently due to 12 a four
year 12 a four of course I have no idea
about the opening I know that this is
the latest tribe but they're forgotten
what black should do the ideas of course
to to get a piece to be five cement and
night down okay let's let's try with the
standard kind of maneuvers lingo I think
this is live from you once and right
yeah life you understand okay so
probably this means he is not in Magnus
team it's got time to play blitz on the
internet so what should I do let's try
to trade Queens here some Queen traitors
usually or quite often in the bank osm
quite okay for black because the
consequence of the central breakthrough
are less severe with Queens off and you
still have this pressure on the
queenside
hmm
who came interesting
yeah trying trying trying for cheap
tricks look at the brook be five but you
can always drive okay 98 now maybe
Bishop g5 I can take on be to another
honor of this of the cheap tricks okay
so he protected the Queen so nights his
heaven is not not possible
hmm yeah it's hard to play without night
see some random hmm
it's not much fun
and I cannot even take on b5 that's
that's a shame
Oh Charlie yeah it's a it's tough if you
play an opening like the Banco and
you're not really know the the latest
ins and outs GM playing one of those
critical lines can really blow you out
of the water quickly this is just a very
bad position probably
it's not easy to make a move him taking
us basically like resigning and just
doesn't really help yeah don't know what
to do yeah as much that I cannot take
I'm actually glad that you play their
phones at least somewhat something like
a weakening of the position so probably
not the problem for him but at least it
looks like there is some sort of
weakness the King position I mean
german night only seven what a piece
trying to do something on the long
diagonal like f5 or ef5 look suicidal
bottom try to get this this kind of
ideas into the game
maybe Bishop before I can get back to it
and then come on wow I can just take it
wow wow what the heck it can just take
take take it on a five why okay what
what no no no use thinking about that
now I need to honey to just play oh my
what the egg okay check
trying for four okay come on hmm yeah
it's got a a 7 s long time warning ya
a7la hmm
yeah I can resign here come on black
vote at five what a move I mean I'm in
terrible shape in this position anyway
but f5 is really kind of kind of
suicidal yeah I was so so eager to make
an active move in this position yeah ki
can basically just sit into ATM but I
like to want to know Queen somewhere
Queen 860 and see what happens yeah I
was really outplayed out of the opening
a foursome currently a fashionable line
I don't know how to how it is somehow it
is best counted the only thing I do is
the way it was played I'm I was terrible
I in this this is just fled winning for
white the position I mean at least in a
normal time control game also lets you
cannot try all kinds of things but it
looks it looks really ugly can just yeah
why doesn't complete control him not
much to analyze I felt like I sort of
decently a yeah sort of continued and
not not losing directly but it's a it's
very difficult to play this position
unlike the f5 of course a suicidal but
yeah it was just like just a terrible in
any way alright thanks for watching